uh mr president thank you so much for
taking your time and talking exclusively
to the public broadcasters across the
whole europe and the whole world at this
extraordinary time
my name is angelina kurkaikina and i'm
from the ukrainian public broadcaster
thank you very much for taking the time
to talk to us to the world's public
broadcasters at this incredibly
difficult time
mr president thank you very much uh
first question how are you and can you
tell us more about your personal life in
this building i know it's not about you
that's what you're going to say but we'd
like to know do you sleep well do you
have time for yourself do you see your
family do you have time to read
first how am i
i feel fine
i make accurate decisions calmly
i think it's important for us to be very
balanced now
our military is showing its strength
it is also necessary to show
balance to remain strong fighters to
defend the state
at the same time to show attitude even
to the enemy
to show human attitude
it is very important for me that people
see that we are defending our state
but i repeat with a human face
that we do not torture people
we are showing that we are ready to
defend
and not ready so to speak to win at any
cost
because this is not a game
and so we are highlighting the
difference between the people who came
to invade our state
who came to our land
it is very important for us to show that
our people are fighting in a civilized
way
that is very important
i'm more focused because a lot of things
depend on me
i want to give only the positive
not in the sense of smiling
but positive in terms of my actions
and i do not want to harm any of our
citizens
people are important because you see
that the people themselves are defending
our state
this means that they are our most
important and possibly only treasure and
protection
this is our iron dome this is our
security union
this is our people
regarding what i read now
i don't read fiction right now to be
honest
i love it
but i understand that i can't
i read the first page
but then by the second i'm already
thinking about what's happening here
so i read the second page again
because i didn't take in what i had read
there
i move on to the third and forget again
because the head the brain are clogged
up with other processes other decisions
it's difficult to relax
mr president ukraine is going through a
very hard time but also it seems united
as never
uh
do you think that this historical change
is taking place not only in ukraine but
in in the whole world maybe maybe in
europe and
what what is to be at the center of this
historical change
the world will change
it has already changed
politicians are already afraid of their
people
they are afraid of social responsibility
they see that people are reacting
differently
and in many countries
people support us 100 percent
but their leaders do not support us 100
for one reason or another
i'm not saying here who is right
but it means that social and public
opinion will be stronger than any leader
in the world
we are all seeing changes in processes
changes that lead not just to
theoretical but to popular democracy
popular democracy is not a revolution
democracy is first and foremost power of
the people
if you want to be the leader of your
society
you have to be the leader of society not
to command
but to be a leader and live with them in
the same
it seems to me that this popular
democracy is taking place in the world
and that this will lead to certain
security alliances
i am confident that there will be new
security alliances in the future
this does not mean that it's necessary
to leave any union
it does not mean that it is necessary to
destroy things that work
no it does not mean that
people just want peace tranquility
stability
and most importantly
confidence
here in all these challenges confidence
be it the new covet or god forbid war
a person who lives pays taxes who
resides here was born or came here
is a citizen of the world for peace
and this person must know
that they must be protected in this
country
and if this person leaves for another
country
the person will be protected there
the person will not suffer
the world is facing just such a
challenge
it will either accept this model and
come to such alliances
or there'll be a change of many world
leaders and their societies will find
proper people for themselves
have you thought about not joining nato
considering the war
and all external threats that are
incoming
in the constitution we have our
intentions with nato
there is ambiguity from nato in relation
to our acceptance in the alliance
there is clarity from some countries
which see us belonging there and only
with them
at a minimum
at least one-third of all countries do
not see us there
some of them will not say publicly
that they'll accept us there
most of them are afraid to talk about it
publicly
that is why we need to revert to the
previous question
they think that society
i think we need to divide this up into
several approaches for this mighty
challenge
in general
we need to find a format in which we
have an understanding of whether russia
wants to stop the war
otherwise
we may
within its borders
and we understand that all these things
we have launched with our western
partners together
then we will have taken the first step
towards the union needed in the world
by being united
we can stop any aggressor
in this moment
that is why i believe in my meeting with
the president of the russian federation
in any format
i repeat it again
and i have repeated it and proposed it
for several years
i know only one thing
our future will not forgive us for the
loss of our population
our state will not forgive us for the
loss of our people
our future generations will not forgive
us for the loss of our territories
and who
but there are those who are not ready
therefore
it is important when we talk about
certain compromises
and crimea to return
this is not a platitude all our people
believe and think so the question now is
when can we stop this war
there is no need for russia to shout
harsh rhetoric
we have an ultimatum
it will not lead to anything
we have an ultimatum
here are the points
you will fulfill them
and then we will end the war
the question doesn't concern only me
this question concerns the fact that the
people and government are united
we're not all going to be able to do
that
you can't do that with ultimatums
ultimatums will not be fulfilled by
ukraine
we just cannot comply with it physically
we've lost people our people
how can we do it
all of us would be destroyed
then their ultimatum will be
automatically fulfilled
for example
give us
yes for example give us mariupol give us
kiev
residents nor the president will be able
to do this
and we even see it in the occupied
cities in malitopol in berliansk when
they enter people will notify each other
they raised the flag and people take it
down
they killed a man so people hid and came
at night and removed the flag
well what do you want
to destroy everyone
that is why i said we will fulfill an
ultimatum only when we do not exist
you can automatically capture this city
but you will live there by yourself
you will work there by yourself
people will either leave the city or
those who cannot leave will fight to the
end
therefore an ultimatum is a bad thing
because it will lead to genocide and the
destruction of the ukrainian people
we are so energized now
therefore it comes down to dialogue
we are for peace
i repeat it again
even no matter how difficult it is
it is better than war and even though we
hate these troops that are out there
the right word is negotiation
negotiate however you can
but negotiate
do not execute ultimatums
this is an important point
a compromise can be found in dialogue
for me any compromises are relevant
because as you know this hatred will be
for every word for every demand
for every course
for every guarantor of security
for everyone
you understand right
time must pass
agree that troops are withdrawn
and that there are certain security
guarantors
here you can find compromise
there are certain guarantors of our
security
they must say tomorrow that they are
accepting ukraine into nato
and not being unclear anymore
or say we're not accepting it now
that is true
and they themselves understand that they
do not want to go with russia so they do
not accept us
the answer is very simple
we already understand everything
we're not accepted because they are
afraid of russia
that's all
and we need to calm down and say that
say okay we need other security
guarantees
there are nato member states that want
to be the guarantors of our security
which unfortunately
can't provide us full membership in the
alliance
but are ready to do everything that the
alliance would have to do if we were
members of the alliance
and i think that's a normal compromise
it's a compromise for everyone
for the west which does not know what to
do with us in the nato issue
for ukraine which wants security
guarantees and for russia
which does not want to let nato expand
further
and says that it has had such agreements
with nato countries with the west
and so
a compromise must be found in this
because this will be the end of the war
for russia this is not the end
there is this public letter i don't know
by whom i don't remember by the minister
of foreign affairs or by the president
of russia
stop talking to us with phrases like
denotification etc
we immediately said that this sounds
like an ultimatum
and we do not tolerate this
because as soon as we're accused of
nazism by people who follow in the
footsteps of nazism
then we will not be able to tolerate it
therefore public rhetoric can be
anything it's the business of every
state in this world but this will not be
binding rhetoric
mr president a clarification where are
crimea and donbass in this
they will come later
that's why i'm talking about approaches
i'll finish now
i think this is a very difficult
narrative for everyone
both crimea and donbass
it will be hard to digest for everyone
and to find a way out
we need to take this first step which is
as i've said
security guarantees
the end of the war
at the same time we should also agree
that we are resolving the issue of
temporarily occupied territories
we have to resolve it but after the end
of the war
why because everything is very hot as
i've said
very hot
and so this blockade will end
and after this blockade please let's
talk
at the first meeting with the president
of russia
i am ready to raise these issues
they are relevant
for us the occupied territories are
important
but i'm sure that this decision will not
arise in this meeting
because there is how do you say
if we're completely frank
we will have to talk about
constitutional changes
changes in ukrainian legislation when it
comes to security guarantees
and if we talk about it
it will in any case be decided not only
by the president
but as it is quite a long process
by both the parliament and the people of
ukraine
and when i say the people of ukraine
and these negotiations with the russian
federation
we will still arrive to these
negotiations as we've explained
i did not meet with russian negotiators
but with our negotiating groups there
i explained to them
look when you talk about certain changes
which might be historic
we will not avoid those
we will put them to referendums
the people will have to say and respond
to some of the compromise formats you
mentioned
but what they'll be is a matter of our
conversation and understanding between
ukraine and russia
how
i can tell you with whom i have
very many too many connections not too
many i mean
not too many to be understandable
rightly
i have many a lot of connections with
uh
with uh duda andre dude
i have many connections with
macron
i have connections many connections with
boris johnson
[Music]
with our
i think baltic baltic countries okay so
all are your preferred
[Laughter]
i would like to ask what you would say
to ukrainians when they see
russian troops through their windows in
their villages towns
also in your interview to cnn you
mentioned that if negotiations with
putin fail
then there's a risk of world war three
what did you mean by that
it
says what i meant
is that putin doesn't have plans to end
this war
as ukraine is only a path he is going
down
which is to continue on to europe
first of all
taking baltic states
countries that were part of the ussr
and then other countries that had soviet
armies
and were under soviet influence
i have been saying this to our partners
including mr schultz
that they might end up with russian
troops at their borders
but then we can certainly see that it
would be world war iii
if our negotiations fail
then we can confidently say that it's
not by accident that he's asking for
demands that will be rejected by ukraine
he's setting demands which we cannot
agree to
before saying they simply didn't want
peace
and then russia will go full force
towards the borders of european or nato
countries
um if you
if you were going to meet with mr putin
in 10 minutes
in 10 yeah why not
in kiev
what would you do what would you tell
him what will
and say everything that ukrainian people
think
will we resolve them all
most important of which is to stop the
war
and let them understand that by
destroying us
he will only destroy himself
i don't want us to be known in history
as a nation that doesn't exist
as a president i don't want this destiny
for our country and people
mr president this is this is the biggest
refugee crisis in the uh in europe since
the second world war uh 10 million
people left their homes inside ukraine
three and a half million people are
abroad
what would be our message to to those
people who are abroad and to to people
and countries who took them
everybody needs to become ukrainian
at least temporarily
and everything that matters to you
to feel that pain
not just be concerned
when you are feeling
you will do what you can to stop this
because people
no matter who they are and what they do
they still think about themselves first
about their life
so what they can do for their own life
is to be ukrainians
thank you very much thank you so much
i'm